we're back with part two and so is
Nathan this time all bloodied falling
out of an upended train and slightly
better looking if you missed our recap
of uncharted drake's fortune you can
check that out too or just keep watching
this one so how did I hero find himself
on a train carriage precariously hanging
off the side of a mountain well to
answer that question uncharted 2 takes
us back several months Nate is hit up by
his former associate
Harry Flynn and Flynn's girlfriend Chloe
Fraser who want him to help steal a
Mongolian oil lamp from a Turkish Museum
the significance being that it belonged
to Marco Polo and holds the key to his
doomed voyage from China in 1292 the
gang resolves to find polos ships and of
course his treasure this is an uncharted
game after all
the plot thickens when chloe asks x-bow
nate to bail on harry with her once they
split the loot three ways it's all very
sexy and she's voiced by Claudia black
so Nate can be forgiven besides it turns
out the bugger deserves it because as
soon as they have the map to polish
shipwrecked fleet in Borneo which should
lead them to the cintamani stone
Harry double-crosses Nate and he ends up
in jail for three months eventually
chloe and our old pal sully team up to
get Nate out of prison and Sully reveals
that Flynn is working for a former
Soviet intelligence operative Gorn
warlord by the name of Zoran lazarevich
who wants the stone from now on alcohol
and laws since lazarevich is a bit of a
mouthful
the dynamic duo Nate and Sally
infiltrate lasses camp while Chloe acts
as a mole here Nate's discovers that the
stone never left
Shambhala its mythical kingdom home he
also discovers a Papa which is said to
be a passport to Shambala and deduces
that he'll be able to find the kingdom's
entrance through a temple in Nepal after
a confrontation with Flynn Sully nerps
out of any further adventuring so Nate
and Chloe carry on to shangri-la which
has been destroyed by lasers marks who
are also seeking the temple in semi
awkward reunion times the pair run into
cameraman Jeff and Nate's now
ex-girlfriend Elaina on their way to the
temple clearly most of that love story
fell in the gap between games they all
team up and Nate
Chloe delve to the bottom of the temple
where they find a clue to the entrance
of Shambhala
but the cracks start to show when Jeff
is shot in an ambush and Chloe argues to
leave him behind while the others refuse
natan Elena are then caught by Lars and
Chloe's escorted away - lasers train
Lars kills off Jeff the cameraman anyway
and presumably Elena laments having lost
yet another perfectly good bunch of film
natan Elena escape and decide to go
after Chloe
although when they do reach her she
refuses to join them because Nate chose
to help Jeff and Elena while they're
arguing Flint arrives and shoots Nate in
the chest who then causes an explosion
to derail the back of the Train over a
cliff and look at that whip back at the
beginning that only took like five
minutes of explaining Nate escaped the
whole falling to his death and/or dying
in the snow conundrum thanks to a
Tibetan villager named Tenzin super nice
dude Tenzin puts Nate up it gives him
warm clothes and nurses him back to
health
nate meets up with Elena and has a chat
with Karl Shafer an old German Explorer
who suggests that Nate and turned then
uncover the remains of his failed
expedition for the stone decades ago
this seems like a sweet idea until it
becomes apparent that the ice cave
they're searching are full of horned
monsters and Schaffer turns out to be a
former SS officer for the Nazis who
resorted to killing his men to protect
the world from the cintamani stone yet
another nasty artifact for Nathan to
deal with Nate intends in fight off
lasses men plus a gigantic tank back at
the village but Shafer is kidnapped
along with the purba Elena and Nate
pursue lars and his men to a monastery
where they find Shafer dying his last
request is phonate to destroy the stone
before last obtains its power nate runs
into Chloe and gets himself back one
mythical kingdom opening / burr with
which he unlocks the secret entrance to
Shambhala unluckily they're caught by
Lars who forces NATO open the final
passage to the kingdom by threatening
Elena and Chloe the group is attacked by
the same monsters as before and Lars
kills them revealing them to be
Shambhala disguised guardians who are
not a big fan of trespasses turns out
that worked out pretty well for a here
Nate Elaina and Chloe take the
opportunity to escape
towards a main temple of Shambhala and
the cintamani stone which turns out to
be a giant amber as it happens the
actual prize here is the blue sap from
the tree of life which makes those who
drink it nearly invincible Flynn
ambushes them and blows himself up with
a grenade at which seriously wounds
Elaina Chloe takes care of her and Nate
confronts lies just as he's drinking the
tree sap obviously nearly invincible is
not totally invincible because Nate
kills him off by shooting the resin
deposits and the Guardians finish him
off the city crumbles while Nate and
Chloe get Elena to safety the game wraps
up with Chloe convincing Nate to tell
Elena he loves her and then she leaps
Sully leaves Elena in Nate's care the
couple pay their respects at Schafer's
grave and then they totally make out
will they break up in time front charted
three find out in our next recap episode
also for more adventuring in treasure
hunting but mostly the update on Nathan
Drake's love life
you